and now we come to the last animated
film in Disney cember Winnie the Pooh
wait didn't we already do Winnie the
Pooh oh wait no that was The Adventures
of Winnie the Pooh this is just Winnie
the Pooh like what
this isn't biography or something or is
it a reboot like a retelling of the
original movie no there are new stories
that guess is just sort of continuing it
but why don't they call it more
adventures have away the bore the
continuing Adventures of Winnie the Pooh
or give it a different title like they
did the other one either pluie movies I
don't know it's here let's review it all
your favorite characters are back
including Winnie piglet I'll take her
the whole bunch and much like the
original film it doesn't seem like
there's one coherent story throughout
the whole thing well kind of sort of not
really yes I don't know okay let me
explain who is looking for a honey big
shock and in the meantime he finds out
that a or has lost his tail who tells
everybody about it and so everybody
tries to get a replacement tail for it
but none of them really seemed to work
so they sort of leave that story for a
bid and they go on to another story
Pooh tries to approach Christopher Robin
but he miss reads a note and thinks that
he's been kidnapped by a monster called
the Backson I won't dare tell you as how
they came to this conclusion because to
be very honest it's very very funny so
most of the movie is trying to figure
out how to capture this monster called
the Backson and that's really about it
those are the only two stories in this
movie I mean it's done well I guess but
why do we spend so much time on just
those two stories the original had like
a ton of stories and that was awesome
heck even if you wanted to keep it to
just one story that'd be fine too but
they seemed very split apart and even
the way the movie is told it seems like
it's trying to recreate what the first
film was doing you know a lot of fourth
wall jokes with the narrator and just
sort of taking time to let the
characters talk and breathe and just at
moments but what made that one work if
that it had a lot of stories this one
only has two that's very odd when the
film ended I was shocked I was like
really that's it
where's the rest of it there's got to be
more stories you can tell than that but
to be fair they're told pretty well as I
said before the film does recreate sort
of that feel that the first movie did
though just like I said too few stories
but it still has a pretty good
atmosphere and pace to it John Cleese's
the narrator and he's absolutely perfect
he's both dignified but can also sort of
give that sense of humor that the
original narrator had to that's creep
Ferguson as the owl and he's a little
different from the original character
he's a little bit more obsessed a little
bit more full of himself I mean the
original owl was kind of egotistical too
but this one seems obsessed with being
right
which I guess works okay but I don't
know wasn't rabid already sorry that
character wasn't he kind of the stick in
the mud or whatever I don't know it
works okay the songs are really friggin
good songs I guess it was done by the
same people who did Avenue Q and Book of
Mormon in fact one of the writers is
actually the voice of kanga that's
pretty cool they're so good that I
actually thought maybe it was the
Sherman Brothers I thought they came
back to do the music for this movie but
nope it's just the exact same spirit and
the exact same talent it's like your
strike they glad your vibes thank you
got your gone they've all bigger part
they just they kept your doom they still
your you
I guess if I had to point out one other
nitpick it would be surprisingly the
animations a little too good I know I
know I'm never satisfied but when you
look at the original Winnie the Pooh
it's just the perfect amount it's good
animation but still a little sketchy
here the backgrounds are still sketchy
and they look fine but the characters
maybe just a little too clean and on top
of that they serve get Christopher Robin
more human-like eyes and oddly enough I
sort of like the dot eyes which I rarely
do but I think because everybody else
has them it's sort of worked and when
you suddenly see a character that has
those big Disney like eyes it sort of
takes you out of it a bit though not
much and again it's a nitpick I'm just
trying to look for problems the film is
good it has a lot of funny scenes the
characters are still wonderful it has
some great songs the biggest problem
there is is that there are only two
stories and I still don't get that why
did they do a ton of stories especially
when it's called Winnie the Pooh I mean
you can recreate this you're gonna have
so much fun and you'll wait stick it to
two stories to be fair though they're
good stories along with good characters
good songs and everything else I
mentioned before it's not a great flick
but it's a good one if you're a fan of
Winnie the Pooh especially the original
I'd say go ahead and check it out and
folks that was Disney cember thank you
so much for joining me in looking over
some of the most classic and memorable
of Disney animated movies I'm sure you
got your own opinions on these movies so
get out there share them and hear what
other people have to say thanks so much
for joining me and take care
Oh